brooklyn new york just across the east
river from manhattan this historic
neighborhood has become a hip and trendy
place to live
seven years ago kata and marcelo moved
here just after they got married we
always wanted to have a restaurant and
wanted to make a dream come true we
decided to open a restaurant mojitos a
cuban food
we live together upstairs in the
parliament hi guys how are you welcome
marcelo and i will both come out with
different specials all the time i've
been cooking my whole life and i love it
we share responsibilities of the
restaurant he takes the back house and i
take the front house
i do the food the orders the payroll
i do everything
but
a year after we opened the restaurant
things started going very bad
marcelo and i are constantly fighting
just have a look at the rice have
otherwise you're right
how dry marcelo crazy
first
say you don't do nothing isn't that your
responsibility
second
that's not the way you make it i don't
respect marcelo because he doesn't know
how to handle pressure what is the
woburn cheese here you're the sheriff
and you don't know
they will fight in front of customers
pick up the food on time
it gets ugly
because of the fighting we separated two
years ago
i get another apartment in queens and i
and i i live there
we destroy our marriage
and i don't want to destroy my
restaurant there's someone in the bank
zero
we have invested
everything we have like three hundred
thousand dollars
if i lost a restaurant i would lost my
dream i love my baby this is my baby i
sacrificed for mojitos my relationship
but it's kata the most important thing i
have
mojitos destroy
our lives
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
mojito's the restroom about to visit
what i do know is it's the only cuban
restaurant in brooklyn so that has to be
a big plus but what i don't know is why
do they need my help
right
well hello
hi
[Music]
hello first name is catalina catalina
nice to meet you nice meeting you and
you're the i'm one of the owners
chef okay i have a partner marcelo is
his name right we used to be married
we've been separated for two years you
used to be married to my partner oh
jesus this is like water and oil we just
don't mix anymore it's just like
conflict all the time well it's all
about the uh food i'll have a look
through the menu nice to meet you same
here okay enjoy your lunch thank you
oh my god a real interesting decor yeah
it's almost like a sort of
garage sale that we've gone wrong
how are you sir good how are you yeah
randy thank you uh let's start off with
chicken classic soup let's go for the
piscata marinara the tilapia yeah
absolutely i really believe chef ryan
she's gonna gonna like the food
i think that 97 percent of my food will
be great
thank you very much that was very fast
very fast indeed let's hope it's good
[Music]
it's cold
i don't want to be a pain in the ass but
can i have a superhorse
wow let me get that hot for you okay
please absolutely
uh he would like a hot soup not cold
we'll try that uh ramsay's head
[Music]
what happened with the soup
i have a thermometer here boiling hot
you want to check
wanna check with me it wasn't boiling
high
and now he sees it's boiling hot this is
what it is but when it went out it was
before you guys sent something out
please check double check triple check
check one more time yes yes listen
go to your bars
[Music]
i'm sorry about that don't worry just
when i went to taste these
these are so salty
i mean you'd need six mojitos before you
start eating six spoons of that
right
they're disgusting excuse me let me take
this back
what a shame
we're going to get the basics right do
me a favor
try the beans marcelo try the beans
[Music]
listen
my god
there's definitely definitely a lack of
harmony in the kitchen it's called
getting called instead of arguing do it
do it do it do it now i want this one
right like now
oh my god that's going to be a complete
disaster
how you doing yeah fine thank you aren't
you i'm fine can i get you anything else
while you're waiting now i'm gonna wait
for the tilapia okay thank you oh it
becomes all right thank you very much
wow i know i can't believe it
the beans the basic of us
i hope you enjoy it because it's
actually my favorite dish
thank you
[Music]
delicious
wow
you love it yeah he loves it
[Music]
fish is not cooked
the fish is not
cooked ah it's really not
that is a shame i'm gonna bring it back
that's a very big mistake on behalf of
the kitchen
okay
not cooked
raw fish wrong with you guys
it's raw it's not cooked i put the
tester the the oven
this is wrong
this never comes wrong what's wrong
hey excuse me
silencer catalina please look in the
handle pressure heat should not be in
the kitchen at all one two three filters
and everything's coming out wrong
unbelievable
after a terrible lunch service chef
ramsay wants to meet kata's business
partner marcela as well as the chefs
responsible for his meal how are you
fine thank you yeah good and this is
eduardo
okay um let me just tell you something
lunch was a disaster
who is the head chef i am dad you're the
head chef yes talking about the black
beans was that perfect no the beans were
not perfect it was salty who cooked the
tilapia i could it was raw
i could hear a lot of shouting what is
that normal that's how we're here every
day what do you mean every day every
single day aggravates everybody kata's
always pushing me pushing me just say
listen do your thing let me do my thing
which is inheriting and in my thing all
together checking
your performance you're not my boss i'm
not your boss by your back you know what
happened when you are automobile
everything got worse
you still live together no we separated
he lives in
his own apartment and i live here in the
building upstairs upset literally
upstairs
oh dear
okay um
right now i need some fresh air i'm
gonna go for a walk and i'll be in
service tonight watching everything and
try
to do a better job than you did for me
lunch time
okay
i'll be back
even with chef franzia there's
absolutely no hope for this restaurant
to survive
[Music]
after a miserable lunch chef ramsay
wants to see how this feuding couple
handles dinner service guys chef
ramsay's here
please keep focused and do everything
according don't send everything down
that is not right
i think she used uh long-lasting battery
because she's stuck on taco
catalina the pretty girl owner of the
restaurant giving orders to everybody
and don't do nothing she don't do
nothing
what's the last show on the windows
there what is all that the blue borders
it's just for decoration
decoration decoration that's it water
but
what have you colored it with the toilet
bowls
toilet bowls i make the the blue water
and i put it on to put on there
i mean i've heard of restaurants
bottling water but it's just for
decorations just for decorations
not for drink human consumption unless
you've been here
[Music]
has spread of chef ramsay's arrival in
brooklyn hi hoyu and mojitos is busier
than usual
yeah either one of these two tables
enjoy your dinner guys
[Music]
with the first orders in chef ramsay is
looking forward to seeing the head chef
in action
[Music]
are you expediting yes you are you could
open up at least talk
the kitchen stuff we do so much better
without marcelo stop putting the tickets
that i'm already starting there here
because it's all [ __ ] me up he
doesn't know what the hell he's doing he
is not appetizer there is an appetizer
oh yeah you're right
what is that for that's for a3
a3 yes
no i need it
clearly marcelo has no control of his
kitchen oh my god
not only is food slowly making its way
to the dining room
the dishes are not exactly being well
received terrible that is horrible
really that's right
what's up with this empanadas can i have
a regular stuff all right i'll be happy
to help them fix that for you okay
they're undercooked they want them
cooked a little bit more oh
marcelo please keep checking that
everything that comes out we check it
already
we got it we got it we got it marcelo
doesn't expedite he doesn't have
consistency he just like sent things out
just to get him out of the way they
ordered the shrimp quesadilla but the
gentleman says that he really doesn't
like it would you like to order
something instead of that i don't want
to go to go home hungry all right i'm
not prone i'm sorry guys let me have
this
[Music]
question who made this you you guys
should know better how can you allow
food to come out like that nasty no
nasty at all i'm we are doing something
you're gonna tell me that quesadilla is
supposed to be crispy and it was like
soggy
it's not crispy
it's supposed to be nicer the bad part
of kata is that she's not actually
hands-on she's just adding fire you're
trying to stop attack stance she's
making the situation worse
perfect
oh dear
oh
i a beating man he's soulless if that's
expediting well he knows what he's said
at home
qatar well she can definitely talk but
she's not doing anything talk talk talk
talk but nothing being done kitchen's in
chaos and the ration is [ __ ] sinking
ramsay has seen enough of this service
customers are unhappy
and there's chaos in the kitchen
so he decides to take a break from the
madness and check out the food storage
look at all this food in here and what
he finds is an outrageous amount of food
for a failing restaurant how much
produce is in this fridge trays
and trays of produce look they put the
fresh one at the front
and at the back
you've got the squidgy one
marinated skirt
no tilapia that
is what you call dried chicken
that's more chicken there must be
thousands of thousands of dollars worth
of food here
if the cash flow is in the [ __ ]
this
is a big reason why
thank you very much have a good night
guys after observing dinner service chef
ramsay now knows that mojito's problems
are not just confined to a bad
relationship
and subpar food we'll never come here
again in fact mojitos is in much worse
shape than he
thought right let's start off with
tonight's dinner service
or shall i say a disservice
customers
pissed off
dishes
been returned
if each and every one of you want this
[ __ ] russian to work
you all have to reach for a standard
whether you're serving food whether
you're cooking food or whether you're
sending food
at the end of service i
pop downstairs
who does the purchasing in here who buys
the
fish
the meat and the vegetables
me
marshall stay there stay there let me
just show you something
right now i'm pretty nervous because i i
don't know what's gonna happen
just take that out for me please
just bring the whole trail for me i
don't know what's going to happen i
don't know what to expect i'm scared
[Music]
mojitos is over 300 000 in debt i am
amazed what chef ramsay found in the
basement is one of the reasons why
i'm not even gonna look
thank you
okay
[Music]
i was speechless how can marcelo allow
something like this to happen
i've never seen such waste in my entire
life you've got enough food down there
to serve a banquet of five thousand
there's seven of these
down there
seven
i don't know if i'm gonna kill eduardo
first
or i'm gonna kill myself first this
is rapidly shutting down
the restaurant
i've got some work to do and i gotta get
out of there guys
that makes me feel sick i'm the owner
and this is my kitchen this is my place
i should be the one taking control of
the situation
[Music]
chef ramsay uncovered many problems at
mojitos but for this restaurant to ever
work properly he has to understand the
issues between marcelo and conda so he
spends the morning with both of them
okay all i've seen so far is a bossy
angry little princess
the restaurant's suffering on the back
of both of you constantly hurting each
other he does it to you you do to him
and it's so sad and it's affecting
everybody else down the line it's
embarrassing take me back seven years
when you got married
we are together all time everybody say
you are the perfect couple we decide to
have a baby so we started to do
fertilization process in the ivf
and nothing happened i was
putting everything into it
and i was willing to sacrifice and to do
and go through the treatment
but it was no support from him like
while i was on the treatment injecting
myself he was out partying with friends
i was being left alone
that's when i'm like no not happening
you're not coming home to me at seven
o'clock in the morning i'm your wife
yeah so that's when everything started
going wrong how did the marriage break
down gee go to florida for one year and
a half in miami did she meet somebody
else in a moment did you meet another
man in miami yeah i took a trip during
the trip i decided so i was going to
leave him you're not making me happy i'm
not making you happy go your way i'll go
my way do you think it's time that one
of you
says goodbye to the business
and give each other space
i think we'll be very healthy
i won cut off of this business she don't
have any idea of how to run a business
she don't do nothing how important is
the business for you it's everything for
me the person that i was married to
that person doesn't exist anymore he's
gone
and i have to move on
and that's what i'm doing
and i take the loss of my marriage
and i think that's the price that i have
to pay
for my business
so i'm taking it on my business because
that's all i have left
whatever it takes
i'll go to the end
until i feel that there's nothing else
that i can do
i've got a plan
i just i need to see you like it was
four and a half five years ago you know
funny confident and no bickering i'm
committed
okay thank you
stand strong
thank you
marcelo and i if we don't find a way to
communicate if we don't find a way to
get to an agreement
the restaurant is going to go down the
drain
but marcelo really drives me crazy i
don't think it's going to work ever
[Music]
while kata and marcelo have both lost
their passion for each other chef ramsay
wants to know if they still have their
passion for the food one thing i haven't
seen since i've been here is you two
working together so that's what exactly
we're gonna do now
[Music]
with all these ingredients in front of
you
cook me something authentic something
cuban and do it together
oh gosh are we gonna be able to do this
i no argue yes
we can be together at the kitchen
so okay i'll make the shrimp with a
pineapple sauce okay let me do the food
cashew marsala wanted to make chicken
but i wanted to do my shrimp
so we started cooking two dishes instead
of one
very quiet in here are we okay
everything good everything's good is
this dish done together we're doing
delicious [ __ ]
i want to see you two muppets work
together
one dish
oh my god
that's not gonna happen
okay okay okay don't freak just keep
moving okay one dish two
fifty fifty
unbelievable
okay
chicken with potatoes whose idea was it
to do the shrimp whose was it me
simple flavors
i think i did a much better job than
marcelo
hmm
i like them nice that's nice
[Music]
what is that chicken fukase presentation
it's not as attractive as a shrimp
clearly
not blow me away it's mediocre
the shrimp is the dish i'd love to pay
for in a local cuban restaurant
we'll do that as a special tonight yes
[Music]
makes me feel wonderful that my dish has
been chosen for those specials by chef
ramsay an honor okay good now do me one
more favor [ __ ] off out together through
the door see if you can just manage
walking out together
[Music]
while chef ramsay works on another
special with chef eduardo right let's do
something together yes something special
is also happening out in the dining room
kata and marcelo are communicating i
wanted to ask you if you want to switch
tonight i'll be in the kitchen you want
to be here
you come out here you stay up front you
just like follow the lead
works we got to talk to jeff from see if
he allows us to do that oh if he allows
it i'm going to look at you
the people at the kitchen
gonna run out we had attitude
we had
she's a nightmare
chef ramsay's plan for tonight's dinner
service features his garlic chicken and
caught a shrimp with mango salsa
tonight's gonna be a lot better than we
had last night yes
but kata has a plan of her own um chef
ramsay we're gonna be switching places
uh marcelo and i i'm to be in the
kitchen starting he's going to be from
house
[Music]
i mean that that sounds great uh who
came to that decision
we're bothered yes
round of applause
[Music]
[Applause]
so i want fast efficient service hot
[ __ ] food and more importantly you've
got to show me that you can handle those
small changes expedite host serve cook
let's go yeah
yeah
[Music]
hey how are you
welcome to mojito thank you
[Music]
i'm definitely really nervous about
tonight's dinner service i don't think
marcelo does well in the front of the
house okay don't bounce around like a
monkey yeah walk in the [ __ ] dining
room
as patrons enter the restaurant
you will find these places over here
connor takes the helm in the kitchen
while you work for me
so you're here and friar this is your
section i can definitely handle pressure
in the back of the house and it's more
chicken than vegetables and i know i'm
gonna do a much better work than marcelo
how you doing guys we have a couple of
specials tonight it's a lemon and garlic
garden chicken uh we also have uh two
jumbo grilled shrimp with a tropical
salsa we'll take one of those
you want the chicken special thank you
so much
here we go guys first order yes
guacamole and cheese beef empanadas and
then we're gonna have a garland chicken
marinara
thank you team another order the jumbo
shrimp special well done tonight's
dinner service is off to a good start
kata has control of the kitchen one
chicken thank you so much and customers
are enjoying the specials
[Music]
i don't know why but it feels better
tonight way better one catalina is
awesome in the kitchen two guacamole and
chips one tropical shrimp marcelo's
actually better in the front cause it's
less stress on him
thank you so much so he's better than
the front she's been in the kitchen yeah
i believe so three more tickets in total
yeah you look so good and composed back
here that's how you do it hello father
back baby holla back thank you baby
this restaurant is still chaotic but
there's a massive significant difference
qatar can handle pressure a thousand
times better than marcelo and the good
news is the specials are flying out
while the new specials are a big hit
with the diners really good the original
menu is striking out
something else just a very strange taste
to it
what's wrong
he didn't like the
uh
strange taste
okay let's go guys speak up
got that this steak was uh he's strange
taste can i have it up on your hands yes
down the window wake up people
respectful remember who i am
don't give me attitude because i don't
need to give you attitude i'm the most
likely or not you have to listen to me
you're waiting for your sights though
right yeah
wait let me have the ticket what's the
mess for the ticket i'm feeling a lot of
pressure there's loads tickets there's
food coming out wrong everything is a
disaster and chef ramsay is watching us
i need a container for their tickets an
ice bucket i need a spike in the kitchen
because we're losing [ __ ] tickets
right oh my god those sandwiches are not
ready yet almost on amazon when we get
busy kata loses herself she becomes very
confused we have one of our tropical
shrimp that went out already everything
went off she doesn't know what really is
going on
hold on hold on hold on it's chaos
[Music]
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service and the restaurant is an utter
turmoil
there are lost orders we need a spike in
the kitchen because we're losing tickets
unhappy customers
and kata is spinning out of control
hold on hold on hold on mojitos is on
the rocks once again it's not getting
cold we cannot have any more food
waiting for one order only one water for
one ticket like this
five minutes later marinara five minutes
later marcelo get out of the kitchen get
out of the kitchen she become like a
tiger get out of my kitchen
uh go out out of the kitchen okay now
get out of the kitchen
what's what's wrong with this girl it's
crazy
perfect thank you that doesn't leave
there yeah yeah if the kitchen is
getting behind everything is getting
it's not coming out right everything's
going wrong have to like take control
and do something take some action all
right guys this order we have to make it
perfect
perfect yeah here we go yeah okay so you
need two turrets on medium two garden
chickens one pescado marinero one
milanesa breaded
is a chicken coming
yeah
after a good start a miserable middle
cotta pushes for a strong finish take
that take that take okay
kata seems to be
doing better two chickens yes nice now
she's got a better grip on tickets on
expediting take that chicken mama
well done
tonight was so much better than last
night a lot smoother
good night
after an up and down service chef ramsay
knows that for mojitos to reach its
potential that is beautiful kata and
marcelo have to be on the same page
okay first of all tonight was better but
let me tell you we can't just get by on
two specials we need to be consistent so
it was a small step forward
now we have to take a giant leap forward
that will be done tomorrow we're gonna
relaunch this restaurant
i'm gonna be working on the menu
throughout the whole night
but
before i leave you here i'm gonna ask
you a very serious question
and i spent a lot of time with both of
you and i i i totally accept that the
possibility
of a husband and wife scenario is not on
the cards
that is not going to happen
but you both own the place and what i
need to know from both of you is that
are you prepared to put
the grievances
your egos your frustrations your anger
aside and completely focus on your baby
and that is the mojito restaurant
because if you can do that you've got a
strong possibility
of making this place work if you can't
then we have a big [ __ ] problem
good night
[Music]
it's up to us
[Music]
let's go
i hope
in my heart
cat and me can work together i think
we're gonna be on track
with the belief that kata and marcelo
are committed to working together chef
ramsay and his team spend the night
giving mojitos a much-needed makeover
[Music]
good morning welcome to mojitos wow the
new mojitos yes
doesn't it feel like twice as big hello
this looks for me
blocking out all that natural light was
crazy
look how bright this place is it looks
gross
first thing that's gone missing are the
500 bottles that was stopping all that
natural light oh that's beautiful take a
look at where your bottles have gone
love
no more blue rings cleaner
it's the new beginning of the restaurant
that's so happy casa what do you think
this is amazing this is a huge step
moving forward and this has like inspire
us and like give everyone the spark that
we were missing to keep going and keep
working hard great restaurants yes yes
now you need
a proper menu
the menu's been cut in half why we need
speeds yes
we keep it small we keep it fresh and
more importantly we no longer need to
keep ten thousand worth of ingredients
downstairs that's not been turned yes
yes you happy
extremely yeah
good
unbelievable and then she had a crying
like a
like a baby huh
i really feel really happy for her
i'm so happy so so so so
so happy today is the beginning of a new
chapter inside mojitos thank you
all right come here
you know firecracker
this is the best yes this is the best
with the renovation done and marcelo and
kato's relationship on the mend chef
ramsay has done away with the cafeteria
style food and in its place contemporary
cuban cuisine look at the difference in
the portion size first bake cod
meatballs entrees slow roast pork raised
short rib authentic and sumptuous it's a
lot less but visually it's beautiful
from the new menu i find a lot of
exciting new things wow meatballs
wow
i'm so excited i'm really looking
forward for tonight
for relaunch night with chef ramsay's
blessing cod and marcelo decide to work
the front of the house greeting
customers leaving chef eduardo in charge
of the kitchen are you convinced you can
do it yeah
hey marchelli two seconds
i've managed to get a really amazing vip
guest here this evening
he's the president of the brooklyn
borough so we are looking after him yeah
thank you
everything's on the line tonight marcel
and i have to come together otherwise
we're going to fail
welcome to mojito how many are you guys
four halloween
for the first time in five years
brooklyn's only cuban restaurant clearly
has a buzz in the dining room awesome
thank you gentlemen so much and as for
the kitchen
it's a different story
very quiet here guys huh eddie two
orders on yeah nothing called out you're
not gonna call the orders out to the
team
those tickets come in you've got to be
in control big boys yeah good man your
food should be out any minute okay
with chef eduardo's lack of
communication food is leaving the
kitchen slowly be right back with the
beans and when it does arrive in the
dining room
some customers received dishes they
didn't even order a cuban sandwich
guys
f5 is missing a cuban i thought what
came back just blame that's because the
order of cuban sandwich not the pork not
the boys
look at me now you've got to call out
the [ __ ] orders because he's cooking
blinds okay yep so he needs some form of
direction
yeah and don't forget to send bean out
with every order oh wow
depression's full great atmosphere
unfortunately food started coming back
and eduardo has [ __ ] shut down not
tonight because this could be a [ __ ]
disaster
i thought we got six
well we did order six
another chicken
we ordered a mix of uh all the different
flavors
i'm so sorry they got they got obviously
their information mixed up back there i
see tickets coming back because eduardo
was completely lost hey guys
f4 is missing more empanadas they have
one of each and we got a little too fast
come
welcome to on oh thank you enjoy the
food and this is the table especially
for you okay
yes
the president of the bordeaux is here
and the kitchen is a disaster
completely disastrous
what is this so we can start taking it
what's table
the steak's cold as well
the president of the world is here ed is
not next for that he's not talking he's
not communicating if eddie doesn't start
to speak up this kitchen's gonna go down
it's relaunch night and the president of
the brooklyn borough has arrived
and the timing couldn't be worse
eduardo is a mess and chef ramsay knows
he has to step in turn those states over
two seconds with me two seconds
literally two seconds
come on what's the matter huh what's the
matter
[ __ ] all over i know you're [ __ ]
all over the place what are you not
doing for you for me for the restaurant
no one's talking
okay i'm gonna put my dishwasher into
frying because i need to do something
okay i guess okay okay come on dude
[ __ ] me talk yeah chef just do something
but talk come on
[Music]
the president of the bordeaux is here
and the kitchen needs acne right now i
have to do something and i have to do it
now we go here we go let's go let's
expedite this
we're cotton trading pescado marineros
okay
nice here we go that's the most
important order of the night that's one
guy we cannot afford to piss off tonight
exactly
guys we need more plants can we do we
have more just come in and try give me
five give me five thank you brilliant
thank you
kata and me are working together well
again i'm gonna do this and you do that
let's go with kata and marcelo finally
working together as a team all right the
kitchen is back on track this is b3 b3
and now the only thing left to make the
night a success is satisfying the
borough president was everything here
they
[Music]
to control the whole situation he was
very put together very calm very relaxed
he really got things going and that made
me gain
more respect for him
well it means a lot for us for you guys
to be here i appreciate it thank you
thank you nice to see you best wishes
thank you that's it that's it i think
that the passion is back i'm back i'm
back again thank you thank you so much
[Music]
together like the team they once were
and mojito's relaunch was a success
right
tonight wasn't perfect but i did see one
thing that i haven't witnessed at
mojitos for the first time and that was
teamwork well done what do you think
about the future of this restaurant now
before it was really uncertain we didn't
know if we're going to last a month a
week a day
now we have a long-term future
it's up to both of you
are you seriously willing to put your
past aside
and
commit to your baby
i already start
i feel great this night
i get the energy that i had five years
ago
it feels great to see marcelo's smile
him showing his emotions it just
started right in my heart
do me a favor
tell each other how important it is
you are my partner and i need your
support and under your commitment so if
you committed to me i'll be 110 120 200
committed to you
to make it work into the restaurant i
need you
to continue
you are the the half of that i'm gonna
do everything that it takes to make it
work you guys work well together
tonight prove that
i feel in in my heart
that i
get
kata back i get my partner back
don't stop you'll be mad too come on my
dog
[Music]
thank you good to see you guys
great team
[Music]
what a night
when i first arrived i honestly didn't
think it was possible that qatar and
marcelo could actually work together but
tonight they proved me wrong now
i'm wondering if the restaurant that
actually ruined the marriage could now
be the restaurant that saves their
marriage
[ __ ] me only time will tell
you live and hope
get me a strong mojito